[Musique]
c'est quelque chose du jardin c'est une
grande ville répit se déploie comme ça
donc dans l'espace c'est une ville qui a
explosé c'est du béton c'est de la
poussière sa déconstruction partout des
petits points des petits carrés des
petits traits c'est la ville de hauranne
oui ce tekken réalise ce dessin à
l'encré de chine en 2017 alors qu'il est
étudiant dans la ville chinoise
deux ans avant qu'elle devienne le
berceau de l'épidémie du coronavirus
j'ai fait ce dessin là qui a été
vraiment un déclic pour moi j'ai je sais
pas j'ai senti quelque chose quand je
les fais c'était c'était assez fort je
vais conserver jeu les ramener en france
mais ça je le vendrai jamais ensemble de
cinq est très précieux pour moi
on dort à l'heure
diplômé d'une école de commerce est de
retour en france il sait désormais que
son avenir sera fait de dessins et de
peintures après les dessins géométriques
très minutieux et très précis de ses
débuts il se met à la peinture à
l'acrylique et ajoute de la couleur dans
tous les petits car j'ai fait en couleur
brique c'est les cheminées d'orléans ça
m'a toujours fasciné parce que là on a
une vue sur les cheminées et toutes les
cheminées sont en briques
[Musique]
la cathédrale sainte croix la loire une
statue de jeanne d'arc sur ses toiles
commandé par un client
il représente orléans sa ville natale il
l'a pas à sa façon comme ils la voient
comme il imagine aussi très coloré pour
cela il utilise des marqueurs qu'il
remplit avec des mélanges de couleurs
qu'il fait lui-même
je pense à 100% du temps où je peins je
regarde le tableau pour savoir ça c'est
cette couleur-là ce beige là que je veux
ici c'est ce ce rouge un petit peu
bordeaux je veux un bleu comme ça je
veux un bleu plus turquoise avant la
bonne couleur c'est ça qui va créer le
tableau ce qui est important c'est
l'enseignant c'est la nuance kaptan fu
faire venir ses couleurs c'est ça la vie
d'un peintre
et le
beyond
[Musique]
non
l'univers de lewiston un mélange de
formes et de couleurs
un style qui oscille entre l'abstrait et
le figuratif
la palette des possibilités semblent
infinies pour ce jeune autodidacte de 26
ans
[Musique]